watch everybody i thought i saw ronan v
in here oh gee
i just want to say this up to him we
lost it anyway nonetheless i'm really
happy to be here
thank you uh everybody for joining in
paulo
brooke uh and everybody in here thank
you so much and
yeah tomorrow's gonna be interesting you
know like
the the web 3 stuff is no joke right
you know i look at the zed drops you
know
top shot within rohan and those guys go
guys and gals have done something
incredible
they pushed back two hours today with a
trillion engineers so
it's been it's been a challenge and
just a huge shout out to the mft 42 crew
who i'm working with
we're going to announce a new platform
called nameless
uh tomorrow along with this launch so
that's been exciting real on chain gang
um learned a lot super excited about it
and was looking forward to this
clubhouse it's just great to see so many
people
in the chat that i'm friends with
you know that i admire that i'm just
glad are here tonight and i'm i'm ready
to answer things and jam and
wherever you guys want to take it hell
yeah awesome
look i i got sent that in the tweet that
you're dropping tomorrow for
5 55 pm time right away
that's at 2 55 on the west coast and i
believe
in the uk it's 10 55 p.m
yeah it's going to be on vfriends.com
i wanted to you know i'm building out an
intellectual property
i think that is gonna be the nft legacy
i think um well i think there's gonna be
a million things excuse me but
one of the things i'm most excited about
is i view
the nft platform the way i think movies
and video games and books have been
and cartoons and toys have been looked
at in the past
you know anybody who follows me somewhat
closely knows i love garage sailing i
love pop culture
i love baseball cards and action figures
and comics and
you know i've i've i built vaynermedia
to buy nostalgic
brands and ip it's why i did the k-swiss
deal because it was an old-school
sneaker brand and like for me i just
never thought that i would have you know
i didn't think of myself as like
angry birds like i wasn't gonna develop
a game that wasn't in my dna
i wasn't gonna develop a movie i wasn't
gonna write a fictional book
like there was just no path for me to
create
my own intellectual property that i
thought was authentic to me and
comfortable and
i felt that i could nail there's
something about the nft part
and the way i'm doing it that falls a
little bit more into maybe more into
like the magic the gathering pokemon
realm of like cards with characters
that really feels real to me and so
it drops on vfriends.com um
and uh and i'm pretty excited about it
that's so cool i mean i think i think
the whole
nft world is excited about it gary that
that one week
push and wait made everyone even had
everyone hyped up even more but i think
it really had everyone even
think about the metrics of your drop you
know like you were very
uh secretive about it only showed a
selected few and we were all tweeting
like oh we saw this job it's really cool
but
nobody really got to see what the drop
is and i think it was awesome that you
you kind of you know you put your
website right there
yeah once once once once i knew that
we weren't going to make it and i just
felt like you know it's funny
i come from such an e-commerce
background and kind of went through that
web one to web 2 world and
we're just so spoiled in web 2 right
like
amazon services and [ __ ] stripe and
shopify like you know the
i just really didn't feel like it was
prime time i think a lot you know
i also am empathetic like i know a lot
of people that are going to
look at this are going to be first time
and i just
really wanted to be have it right and so
once i realized we weren't dropping last
tuesday i was like okay
wednesday i don't remember anymore but i
was like
i'm not gonna hold back the information
like i wanted to hold back the
information in dutch because i was
extremely scared because i had so many
talking about supporting me and this and
that was like man
are are like people going to buy these
up like and just resell them like how do
i protect
some people that have really just put
together the 0.5 to 3e
depending on the i dutch auctioned i was
worried about them going high
so just thought about a lot of stuff
thought it was the right move to put out
much more information about
the project i think you know the you
know it was very important to me to
create like
the conference some of the access stuff
the gift codes
the hangouts wanted to show that there's
a lot more we could do with the nft
projects for me personally
it was also a play to create value in
the short term while i go
and try to you know land somewhere
between
pokemon and the smurfs right that's kind
of how i keep talking to myself about
this which is like
what can i actually do with these
characters over the next 40 years in
consumer package goods and
in books and animation
in streetwear collaborations like i'm
genuinely
i've i enjoy being the human behind
garyvee
but being garyvee is tough right because
there's a lot of things i'm passionate
about but i'm
aware that 35 percent of people are
going to tune me out immediately because
of
my style of communication i think being
a human
you can only make so much impact but for
me like having empathetic
elephant or patient panda or all the
things that are now at my disposal from
an
ip standpoint some of the things that
i'm passionate about look i
i've said this consistently i'm an
incredibly big byproduct of very good
parenting
and circumstance so i have a lot of
gratitude and i have a lot of things i
want to share about
being an alpha winner needs to be more
around sympathy and compassion and
kindness
and patience and being the bigger person
not about like
flexing and like scolding somebody in a
meeting or
thinking you're hot [ __ ] and what's
ironic is my energy as a communicator
makes it very difficult to a certain
demo for me to land that for another
demo it lands
but having these characters at my
disposal now for
the things i'm passionate to put into
the world is a real blessing and i'm
very grateful and i'm excited
i love that yeah you are excited about
the characters and you started joining
them a
long time ago as well so it's uh
you know what's funny i you know i would
prob you know by the way on that note
a lot of the early nights here in
clubhouses everybody remembers
the early nights only three months ago i
was in rooms here defending
nft artists that like their art was
actual
art and that you know a lot of the
establishment was super
ridiculous about their point of view
what's been most fun
for me is watching so many that i've
defended razz me and say that my doodles
aren't art
and i'm like jesus yeah it's amazing in
a hundred days how people
you know but you know for me probably
the one i chose to be the mascot
um when you see the logo on vfriends.com
if you go right now
i i drew a character called the very
very very very lucky black cat
mainly because i don't want black cats
to be bad luck
it's just really as simple as that i
just don't want it
and i'm going to put my marketing
machine in my 45 years of effort to
change the narrative
i was talking to a friend who's like no
you can't do that it's hard
like it's possible or something i was
like you know pink was the primary boys
color
in society 150 years ago right and
i had no idea and so like i love that
kind of [ __ ] like
you know that it was marketing and
communications that
you know created a scenario where
you know diamonds were given for
engagement like there's a lot of things
that
you can do like people are very bad at
history
back to history there was a time when
humans walked the earth and didn't value
gold
like history is misunderstood and it's
incredible
indicator to the future and so my
favorite character is taking
a character that has an extremely
negative
point of view in our society and i'm
going to enjoy myself
and the process of seeing what i can do
with the flip of that narrative so
there's literally a black cat sitting on
top of my name and my logo and
i would say that's my favorite though i
will say that patient pig and patient
panda
i'm a very big fan of patience i think
people are very confused by
for everybody in this room i think
people are just incredibly confused by
how much more time they have to do their
thing
um and i i'm a big fan of patients and i
think a lot of people have a lot of
anxiety and unhappiness
because they haven't done what they
thought they would do at 27 or
32 or 41 and i think that's unfortunate
and
i think a lot of our societal norms are
based on when people died at 45.
so the patient characters are very very
big on my list
yes i love that i love i really enjoy
the characters but
i love how you speak about the very very
very very lucky uh
black cat you know changing the
narrative and telling your narrative but
what you had me thinking right now
changing the narrative the whole
narrative in
life and society the digital revolution
right so it's kind of like it fits in
the mold
exactly what's happening right now with
the narrative being completely shifted
and everyone moving on chain
uh i think it's super cool or even this
um we have g money on here with the with
the eight funk and everything i mean
things are changing so
yes they are yes they are i mean
oh my god i mean g money you were
telling me you were the one telling me
you know you should seriously
get this get this puck and we had a
conversation about everything changing
what do you make of
of the friends and and the drop
everything have you had the time to look
at it because you're like you're like a
super og
yeah i mean um i looked at it last week
um
before in the in the private showings
like i think
a day or two before and i was really
impressed with it right because it's
like
a lot of times people will reach out to
me and be like hey like i want to do an
nft
and a lot of times it's just you know
like a piece of art or
you know something like a collectible or
whatever it is they want to do and i'm
like
you kind of like need to offer something
more as like a value prop right
so i think that that's something that
gary's doing really well is that
you know there's there's gonna be like
some residual value here like there's
gonna be a reason to collect these right
which i think you know you've seen
um your fair share of of people that
just don't engage with their community
right because it's like it's ultimately
like
you're doing this for your fans and for
engagement so if like you were to sit
there
and just kind of like drop an nft and
then just walk away
it's like the same as like you know
pumping a coin and like dumping on your
on your followers right like it's like
the crypto equivalent of that so
i love the fact that like what he's
doing is like super innovative you know
you're taking it to the next level so
it's gonna be exciting to see how
how other um nft drops start upping
their game after this
i appreciate that brother yeah i mean i
think you know
i've been dropping videos of me talking
about ethan 17 and 18 just to give
people a little context like
you know i think i'm so loud that people
forget
that you know i try and you know why in
the world would i ruin my reputation so
i try not to talk about [ __ ] i don't
know and i watch
and i wait for that moment and you know
as you know gmoney we met a little while
ago and me and aj have been on a very
deep deep deep dive versus a casual dive
and
first i spent an enormous amount of time
on punks and
just all the different chains you know
and just getting a sense of
where i felt comfortable like i mean
this has just been the story of my life
right like
e-commerce all the og liquor store
owners made fun of me
youtube was a complete like had i lost
my mind
social was ridiculed
you can't imagine the
jokes that people made about me when i
started an agency in madison avenue
and you know i have a lot of compassion
to why there's cynicism or doubt
but it's an incredible oxygen for me
like
you know i feel like my whole career has
been
led up to this moment like i loved
creation i mean i i would i created
myself in a way right like
i love character creation i love this i
understand it
i mean i literally garage sale to buy
pop culture
right so i am i feel extremely prepared
and
obviously i care about the short term
and
you know i created a lot of offline
triggers to make sure i support
people that support me to the best of my
ability but
you know this is for me a very long game
like
dramatically longer than i think anybody
even my inner
as my inner circle started like peel
away their time with me over the last
three months i think people got a little
bit more
oh okay and so i'm excited i'm genuinely
excited i'm like
so nervous because i think tomorrow i'm
worried about like
that first hour there's always like i
mean just reading the zed and top shot
comments every day like scare the [ __ ]
out of me because i'm going to want to
reply to everything tomorrow
and i have a whole bunch of noobs so
it's going to be a really interesting
day but
i haven't i haven't felt like this in a
long time tomorrow's a little i i've
i don't i haven't been nervous in a
little while which
means i'm really on to something so i'm
excited
yeah i mean you know what's really well
exciting to hear you being
like that i remember when i when you
showed us with paulo the
the at the project and i text i say yo
what am i about to tweet that you're
like
that i'm gonna spend 45 next years of my
life
on this project and i was like that is
and i
[ __ ] love that you know it's we've
hosted you know we've got a chance to
always follow a lot of drops and a lot
of the times it's just
kind of there's a lot of it's deceiving
right it's deceiving i think you're
you're setting like when it comes to
people with you know with influence and
following from the outside
and you're like damn i wish i had added
a concert ticket to this i wish you had
added something some utility to that
because a utility can be more than just
what people think it's just access
you're tokenizing time and access
in such a brilliant way right because
whatever people buy
tomorrow is 55 it's gonna give them
different levels of access
to you in a way and you've never you
know sold that you know what's funny the
access to me is actually a very like was
a late addition because i started seeing
so many things
not going well and i was like you know
what let me throw this in the mix
so that people can understand you can do
this because i think you know for
example
there's a boatload of people that i hope
follow this model so i can bid on it
like like i want to go in studio with
the weekend like i want to hit
tennis balls with no back joke which
like you know like i'm into that [ __ ]
so that that was that i mean i think the
bigger thing is
the conference is you know what was so
fun for me is
i've been wanting to do this con south
by southwest changed my life
and i've been wanting to do this
conference for
10 years so that's the other thing i
think people can you know one thing i'm
trying to mentally prepare for is
if this goes well there's gonna be a big
number associated with i have 10
255 tokens you know so
you know if it goes really well there'll
be the headlines of big numbers and i'm
like
meanwhile i'm i'm hiring projected 50
people for the animation
like we're building out these characters
right i'm these are
hefty seven figure cost
you know even potentially eight figure
costs on vcon the conference that comes
with every token so
my my accountants were baffled when i
told them when they projected the floor
of this project and i said look we need
to talk about
what happens if we lose money on this
and they just couldn't wrap their heads
around i was like look this is a
this is a corporation you know i don't
have the you know people
and many others who i admire like
they're you know they're they're selling
as artists and
you know that's where it stops and
starts which is incredible in kudos and
i think there's so many great projects
for me i'm building a company
and so at some level this is
i'm not gonna say it's fundraising but
it's like you know i'm definitely
gonna spend the money to build out what
i'm building so
it's and then like just like thinking
all that through when you get those
dollars
or that monies and ethereum and
paying the taxes and having the dollars
to throw on three years of conferences
so
there's a lot of complicated [ __ ] in
this process but
the journey of building out a blueprint
that others can
learn from and tweak and make better and
build on top of
and then much like i did with wine
library tv there was not a lot of long
form
at all videos on youtube and i remember
i'm like i'm gonna do this so people
realize youtube's much bigger than
pirated snl clips because that's what it
was
for all the ogs in this room in 2006
february 2006. um
but then also for me this is like insane
i can't believe i get the
you know luxury of
of trying to like build out an alpaca
character or you know or
or lit or lit lamb or like like like
i've got
i've got real fun in front of me and you
know i've spent the last 12 years very
quietly building
an extremely large 1500 person global
company
with vayner x that just opened an office
in mexico city
has 150 people in asia has 100 people
in plus in london like i built a really
large company quietly while everybody
thought i was gary veeing it
and i'm going to use that infrastructure
to build this
i freaking love that and you know also
another point that i was thinking about
what's cool about
the fact that you pushed your drop a
week i mean your
fans made a heck load of money
with each going up because you had like
a hundred thousand people
learning on discord what is the metamask
what is this what is that how do you buy
eve what is it i mean all your content
leading up to this has been teaching and
educating not just hey
i'm dropping this constantly bye it's
like you're teaching people for weeks
for months
and with the price of literally
skyrocketing
i mean you've you've done you've done
your fans a service
at this stage and i think this is
freaking awesome
yeah to me you know like obviously you
know i think all of this is very
intense [ __ ] and i keep telling people
be calm like
like just do learn learn learn to me
the point that i'm most you know here's
something that the the room might find
interesting
i grew up in web 1-0 truly i launched an
e-commerce website
at scale in 97 registered in 96
and like
people were scared to put a credit card
into a computer
like i would be on a liquor store floor
in 1997
1998 for 20 minutes talking to four
people
in a circle marveling at this idea that
they could put a credit card
into this website and not have to drive
from new york to wine library because we
had such a good store
like they just thought like people were
baffled and they were scared
when my credit card gets stolen and
you're seeing that happen
with non-custodials like people are
scared people are scared to like
connect people are scared to like lose
their seed phrase
people are scared that they might click
something and they'll get their stolen
their their laptop gets compromised or
hard drive like
there's fear and you're right i mean
like one of
you know by far the best part of this
journey is i respect
the ogs and it's funny to say the ogs
but the ogs of 2017
18 the larva guys and jim nft42 and you
know
roham with pick kitties and now nba tom
shot
many many many other women and men and
like
you know many of them have dm me in the
last month
every single day and said you know i
just thought you were another one of
those people i didn't really know your
stuff i heard of you or i saw one
instagram thought you were dick face and
you know
and i've gotten that you know and and
like
that article you put of like how to set
up a meta mask or what is rainbow or
you know like what's non custodial
versus custodial like we put in a lot of
work
and we've onboarded a lot of people and
tomorrow
many people will miss out or decide not
to jump in
and either they've made money to your
point on eath my great hope is
if they don't get what they want or the
floor doesn't get low enough on the
dutch
that they take those you know dollars
and do something by supporting other
projects one of the things i'm most
excited about is after
this launches and i take the dollars i
need for taxes
and v-con and operational maybe
a dollar or two for myself one of the
things i promised myself
is i'm doing two things one i'm gonna go
buy a bunch of jordan rookies and
charizard hollows and and two
i'm going to go and you know i don't
know if some of you saw this but it was
a very big threat i asked about
independent favorite artists and so i
have that thread i'm gonna go back to
and i'm
just gonna take a full day one day and
just go and buy
an ungodly amount of art that i
subjectively think looks cool
not overly thinking that it
will go up or down or left or right but
you know just like with web 2.0 and just
like with the liquor business and just
now with the ad world
i will jump into new things it's who i
am i'm truly a creative entrepreneur
but i love being part of communities
like some of my best friends in the
world i met in web20
and just the 98
of the people i've met in 3-0 on
blockchain or
you know and different and different
chains
polka dot like just like there's so many
cool people just doing such
mutable level two vr decentral
like just just the sheer creativity and
the passion and look
i think there's a unbelievable level of
greed
and short-term behavior because that's
the nature of it like there's a lot of
that going on here
more so than web 2 because you can
actually see things happen very quickly
but it's an incredibly there's so much
more pro than khan
and i think many incredible things are
happening from it and i
and i'm excited to be meaningfully
involved so much
comes to mind right like i'm listening
to you
i know you well i know you both from
you know your persona and from you
personally
behind the scenes and you know what i
just heard you describe is
i'm listening to what may become
the next pokemon franchise
but built on blockchain it's like
sitting down with
you know when they're creating the
founder of garbage pail kids or pokemon
and saying hey
we're doing this but we're doing it on
blockchain i was watching you on cnn and
i was like
so [ __ ] excited inside of me looking
at you
and seeing you being interviewed just
because like i know
er on all things web 1.0
and 2.0 you're you know very
famous for making significant
early investments correct me if i'm
wrong i think
you bought your facebook shares from
zuck's parents and your twitter shares
from
the former cto that walked away and i
look at
all of these things and how significant
you've been
in you know the pokemon let's call it
craze and understanding everything that
you know
understanding your relationships with
you know some of the biggest tech
entrepreneurs in the world
you know hearing you talk about like
[ __ ] i tweeted uber needed a ceo and
travis responded you know and i look at
where you are now with
all of that that knowledge and you know
i
don't take lightly that you built a 1500
[ __ ] person
agency that's a social media influencer
marketing business
in 2021 while
a lot of the people in the world still
don't even know
how effective influencer marketing is
like i think they're still a big part of
the world
that barely are waking up to social
media influencer marketing
because they're now hearing a tick tock
and i look and i sit back and think like
you have so much accumulative
knowledge experience and
relationship currency as you build this
and you shape it
and i hear you you got a vision you
don't
what i hear is like yo this is
[ __ ] pokemon of this dick
built on blockchain first so i just
wanted to share that with you and
congratulate you because
for you to jump out and make this move
again it's different than
anybody else making it right like you're
so visible
you're so in front of everybody you go
all around the universities
yeah we're losing first of all it's very
kind two two
two things um palo thank you two things
yeah two things one
travis actually was the one that asked
me to retweet it and it was ryan graves
who
answered the tweet because travis and
garrett had uber
cab as a side project uber cab was the
first name of the company for
all the kids in the room um second
look pokemon's the biggest ip in the
world now bigger than star wars and
marvel so
you know i i what i want everybody to
hear is like
you know i would i could see a lot of
people that are very knowledgeable
about intellectual property saying
gary's [ __ ] delusional
what the [ __ ] is he talking about with
pokemon it's 90 billion dollar ip like
but i think it's really important for
people to hear this
what what i said earlier between pokemon
and smurfs like
i don't understand why somebody wouldn't
try
to it's you know it's just like
when everyone's like thinks that i'm so
obsessed with buying the jets
i'm obsessed with trying to buy the jets
i'm i'm not obsessed with making v
friends as big as star wars and marvel
and pokemon
i'm obsessed with the curiosity of am i
good enough
over the next four decades to do that
and if it ends up being hannah barbera
then that's insane funny thing happens
when you shoot for the moon
you end on top of very large mountains
as a default price
and so you know if nothing else i think
people very much
don't understand ambition and it doesn't
need to be ground
i think a lot of people talk with
delusion
but i think when you believe you
genuinely have the capability
and you're curious if you can but then
you also have the humility
to you know i have to counter what i'm
saying right now at 79 years old and
saying look
you know 44 years ago i you know 34
years ago i tried
it was harder or this happened or i got
distracted or vr came along and i got
more excited or
or i wigged out in 2037 and
moved to you know a sheep farm in peru
and
[ __ ] loved it you know like whatever
it is it is but like
i think people need to be more
comfortable
with having their ambition i think
equally i think a lot of people talk a
lot of [ __ ] like the amount of people
that roll up on me and say they're gonna
be a billionaire and i ask them three
questions and
they're such devastating answers i'm
like bro
you need to focus on being a hundred
thousand heir you know like and so
i think that um there's a balance there
but yeah i'm i'm
very excited and i'm 45 years old i'm
such a major product
of americana commerce you know cartoons
making toys right thundercats
he-man transformers robocop
alph like you can't imagine
how in the pocket of ip creation the a
team
wwf happened in front of my eyes when
vince mcmahon taken over his dad's
business like
this is um this has been in me the whole
[ __ ] time and there's a lot of
content
there's a lot of funny things in old
wine libraries in 2006 seven eight nine
so feels very authentic to me
it is it sounds very authentic i'm gonna
tell you from a third-party perspective
and it
it definitely looks just as authentic
when you just look at the website you
put together
when you look at like the detail that
went into that in
in and all of it i'm only secure a
supporter is there some subject
rather like on the metrics of the drop
how it's going to happen
like is it all dropping at 5 15. yeah
i'll give you i'll give you i'll give
you a different time set up
yeah i'm i'm dropping it at 5 55 you
know it's moved so much now that we're
here 5 55 p.m tomorrow eastern
i'm dropping 48.72 or something like
that about 50
of the project tomorrow um it's a
five-day drop event
so actually let me pull it up because
the clubhouse is getting the data i'm
sure i see a lot of people from the
discord in here so they'll share it
though i've shared this in there but
it's about fifty percent
um let me give you exactly because there
it is 50 48.72
of the tokens tomorrow 19.996 the next
day
then 11.80 and then nine seven nine
seven so
five day event about half tomorrow
um i'm excited about it
wow and it's gonna be it's gonna be 5 55
p.m
20 hour auctions dutch auctions
give us a four hour break before we
reboot the next day
so that's kind of how i'm planning to do
it
just for everybody to know a dutch
auction is the reverse of the
auctions you used to sell the english
auctions uh they go down
in price as they get bought out exactly
like the larval labs miebe
drop happened it was going down as
mormon bits were being minted
so you capped even how much you can make
on that and i think that's cool
right because you said you meant she
said i don't need a headline saying uh
dinner with gary sells two million yeah
by the way by the way i've been dropping
the prices all day
like as way yeah yeah
i mean originally like i'm gonna reverse
engineer what happens
with the actual results right like
i know i've done a lot of homework you
know i have a very large speaking bureau
too vayner
speakers and we've been doing a ton of
homework on the biggest events in the
world so i have a good sense of what a
three
fourth thousand dollar four day ticket
looks like
so i'm just gonna reverse engineer you
know on that part i mean look i think
i'm building
something very very real in intellectual
property and if i'm right
those things work themselves out but the
conference and some of the access stuff
i you know yeah as ethan's gone up i've
i've adjusted some prices
just because i just want to be fair to
the best of my ability and like
i don't need i didn't need to cut you
know there's only so much you can do if
someone thinks they're paying so much
for a conference and i just need to
think through everyone's psychology i've
been living in my discord
i've been living in my discord um
and so i'm listening listening is how i
make my decisions
i noticed that you also have been in
several discs i admired the grind always
i mean
been seeing it on social media for years
and years and years but i saw you in the
board abe discord
so you're discord you're on twitter like
non-stop and
and your brother too and you guys are
just reaching out to a bunch of people
and
and just you know and both sides i think
that's cool because you understand you
understand community building
and there's obviously a very very very
tight core community in web 3
and uh and even on on nft like
twitter uh for nft space and everything
on clubhouse too i mean i've seen you
drop into run the other day you dropped
into a random small room full of board
apes and you just started
you just came and showed some love and
gave it some traction and just
you know helped everyone else i thought
that was cool you know i
i i will never understand how people are
not driven by gratitude
the like i'm i wish you understood what
my brain's doing right now when you said
that
the thought that i jumping into a
clubhouse and giving love
is like some great gesture is
so uncomfortably flattering and humbling
and is a is a difficult thing to like
swallow
like which is what drives me to do it
like
the thought that that i mean
for everybody in the room that's over 40
do you remember when
nobody gave a [ __ ] about a business
person like i do
because i was one at 12 and 14 and like
literally bill gates was the only person
that anyone talked about and he was such
a [ __ ] nerd i couldn't even get my
head around like looking up to that you
know i was like you know but like
the fact that entrepreneurship is you
know like
so there like it's crazy
to like feel like that and like of
course i want to give love it's why i
always stop it's why i always talk it's
why i want to do stuff like that it's
why
i've dm'd a drillion artist and saying
what's up
it's so i mean the talent look
it's very funny i a lot of people are
you know a lot of people like my doodles
but a lot of people are razzing and i
get it they're not like it's not the
most complicated thing of all time but
i really like them and like like i
really think they're good characters and
like
oh by the way snoopy is not so [ __ ]
complicated to draw
oh you know like like like you know it's
not so intense
and so like bart simpson's not the
hardest and so like
you know and by the way bart looked
ridiculous the first season on tracy
ullman
that [ __ ] upgraded if you don't think v
friends are going to upgrade once i
[ __ ] blow this out and steal all the
[ __ ] animators from disney and pixar
you're [ __ ] nuts
so you can make fun of my early [ __ ]
renditions but
like i'm not [ __ ] around here and
you know when [ __ ] accountable aunt
shows up on book bags and you know you
know
rare robot is flexing all over graffiti
like everyone's going to remember this
clubhouse and be like [ __ ] you really
did it
yeah i love that but at the same time
like who are we to
say what is nice what's not right artist
objective
and and art is what you're true to and
it doesn't matter
i saw some people on twitter we all saw
that but at the same time
it doesn't mean anything i remember even
seeing oshini tweet
and he was saying and he's a very large
collector and a great person
and he was just like it doesn't it
doesn't matter what what garyvee's doing
is beyond
even the art itself well that's
that's been the part by the way that's
been the most fun for me
i almost feel like i'm doing like a
muhammad ali rumble in a jungle
rope-a-dope
i think which is exciting because it's
really working out for me
i wanted to show that there was so much
more than the technology of nfts
right big shout out to aaron battalion
an incredible
you know developer who's the cto of
livingsocial who made me buy ethereum in
2016 at south by southwest
and really taught me he's like this is
how it's different than bitcoin it's a
platform and i did it
and like you know i mean the reason i
have videos in 2017 talking about
you know people buying homes and leases
and contracts like
was because of him and the learnings i
did then and
you know that was very important to me
in this project but i'm excited
because right now the attention is on
vcon and
gift code and sitting courtside with me
and dinners and all this random [ __ ]
and meanwhile i'm like okay good now
everyone's paying attention to that
for the next three years let me go build
raggedy ann
let me go build shirley temple let me go
bail popeye the [ __ ] sailor man
let me go [ __ ] build super mario like
it's gonna give me time
and i'm gonna [ __ ] do it
yeah if you you definitely sound like
you're gonna do it we know you're gonna
do it
so far everything you said you do you
did uh i mean i've
only been following you for like what
six years now which i think is a lot
but uh but uh every single call
everything is funny because
they laughed at you too and i told him
about that two days ago they laughed at
you too when
when you defended facebook billion
dollar acquisition of
uh instagram right and and it's funny
because right now
same people are laughing at the nft
space and this and that but i don't i
generally think that the people are
going to be laughing on people
now now on the flip side before everyone
here gets
too high on the kool-aid like
the investments of a lot of projects are
not going to work out it's not that
they're not good projects
it's that the supply and demand is going
to be completely impossible
like let there be no confusion there's
going to be
three four years from now where almost
everyone's gonna have nfts definitely
every intellectual property that means
anything
every athlete every actor every
influencer
every league every video game every
comic book
like it's just gonna be overwhelming
it's gonna be like social media
like in 2009 when i wrote crush it if
you go read the first hundred reviews on
amazon people like this is ludicrous
you can't make money just being yourself
on social media
now it's the one of the biggest
economies in the world and
85 percent of people under 18 aspire to
be an influencer
that's exactly what's going to happen
with nfts like
there will be the people that led blouse
and others that did incredibly well
but now we're in the place where you
have to really launch a significant
project
you know and it's going to get harder
and harder and harder but that doesn't
mean you can't come along just
you know look at charlie demilio like
she came along and became a very large
influencer on a new platform
years after influencer marketing and
instagram was real and youtube was real
mr beast wasn't there first on youtube
like so
if you can do it you'll be able to do it
but i
i wanna i really think that people
on the nft thing right now the macro
technology
is a foregone conclusion there is almost
no rationale
for any brand or business not to issue
nfts in five years
when costs collapse to do it you're
creating marketing
material and you're creating a
collateral
royalty asset that could just be
giving you derivative passive value
if it becomes a collectible there's
gonna be no reason not to
on the flip side currently
there's going to be a lot of things that
are bought that are not going to be
worth as much as they're worth today
in six years even though nft will be as
normalized as social media
i [ __ ] love that music to my ears no
fungible's here what's up gary hey
brother how are you great bro it was
awesome the other night when you walked
us through
your nfts i i have to say i'm i'm
i'm surprised that peroque is even
maintaining composure right now to be
able to interview he's doing great
because
we've been aping all day uh
he was into some heavy positions bro and
he's like i gotta jump on and talk to
gary i'm like i don't know how you doing
we're training on defiant
it's been it's been nuts today but you
know one of the things
i wanted to ask you because you know i
think the way you've done it obviously
with the utility aspect is brilliant and
that's what we're all about
um it you know what's happening around
these and gas fees like today
each transaction was like four or five
hundred bucks yeah so you mentioned some
other blockchains right like polka dot
solana kusama which is one that we're
building on top of
and obviously those fees are nominal um
right now everything's going nuts
because ashima got listed on uh bybans
so uh you know what are your thoughts on
using other blockchain
technology and also just even tomorrow
with the drop for you know
because i we had an investment we did
today and they came out and
people were like hesitant to buy because
like 500
for gas you know one of the things let
me let me be very clear here
a couple things great great stuff thank
you brother um one
other blockchains can't wait i just have
had the luxury
luxury i don't know i just have been so
close to eth
from the way out and over the last six
months
the way close and it was just where i
had to do it because i'm
i'm scared to do things i don't
understand so it was where i was most
prepared to do it on
um this is clearly the beginning of the
next chapter
of my career the nft thing you know it's
funny
trading finance like
one of my favorite communities in the
world is the bitcoin community i think
that community is just legit
stick together lots of stuff and like
even beyond the financial ramifications
of the value
love to watch that community um i bought
bitcoin in 14.
i i bitcoin
is kind of like stocks for me like i
don't buy wall street stock
it just doesn't happen i never do it i
don't like that
i like tchotchkes i like sports cards i
like
things i like that's what i like so for
me nft spoke to me
so you know what i'm excited
for this next chapter for myself and i
feel like you know
aj and i are raising we'll be announcing
very shortly after v
friends of a fund so we're investing in
companies in the space
an nft only fund i'm working on
significant things in the vayner world
on it
this will be a very big part of my life
uh which means
to your point polka dot which i'm very
curious about like i want to know
everything
and i will i'm busy as [ __ ] which sucks
like it's not going to be 2007 where
like i had wine library cruising i brand
warnicky my
best friend in right hand running the
company clean and i was able to actually
spend 15 hours a day
in it i don't think i have that luxury
this time around so it's going to take
me more time
and it's [ __ ] a lot like it feels
like you know you guys know this
every 72 hours is like oh you don't know
about this you suck i'm like [ __ ]
like you know didn't exist an hour ago
like
i'm sorry so like you know like there's
so much to learn
but yes first of all i have to be very
thoughtful
of what i do with nft drops i'm pretty
committed to be
friends for rest of my life and so if it
goes sensational
three years out could i see myself doing
a series two
it's run through my mind you know one of
the things i've been worried about is
so many people blocked out from this
because of the price
the way eath has evolved how expensive
my company is to build
so i've been thinking about a low-cost
token
in the friends world at scale doesn't
give you access to b con to be unfair
i have to think of that through but
that's a that's probably where my head's
at most right now i'm like what's the
half of e thing
that i can put out that everyone can get
involved in so it's kind of like
it becomes this cute little like you
know i don't know how many of you were
sports cards but like
every year cards would come out but then
people get traded and new rookies would
come up
so there'd be that mini like updated set
tops traded
flea or update so like i was like oh
maybe i'll do you know
so you know i think and and maybe that
doesn't need to be on eath by the way
and maybe it does
like but cancer i'm going long-winded
because i'm enjoying myself jamming with
everybody here
yes i feel like it'll be very unlikely
for me not to
get involved and and more importantly
one of the reasons i keep bringing up
polka dot
on surface level i understand that
they believe in a world that i think i
believe in which is this is not a winner
take all world
i don't think this is east or flow or
you know salon like i i think this i
think that there are
multiple chains that matter in a decade
and i'm excited about that i want to
learn everything and as far as gas
prices
i'll use this platform to say something
i haven't said there's a part of me
that'd be just as excited if everything
hit the floor and nobody bought a damn
token
because i know exactly what i'm gonna do
and so
like i'm excited by whatever happens and
if people balk
because of the gas price i'm empathetic
to that because
nobody should spend any money on
anything that they're not
educated on believe in fully about
and i i have no entitlement to what
should happen tomorrow
it could be a massive quote-unquote flop
for me if things sell at the floor i'm
thrilled
of course i make more money if they
don't that's fine i'm an entrepreneur
i'll take it i'm not going to cry about
that i'm happy
but you know if if they all just sit
there
you know look at moon cats that [ __ ] was
discovered years later
if if they all just sit there i'm i'm
still trucking to what i'm doing and
i have a funny feeling as i start
announcing what i'm doing
different things will start happening so
we'll see
that's awesome bro by the way if you uh
if you want to check out um what nfts
can really do
like crazy technology um let's chat i'll
hit you up
yeah i'm really excited about what
you're doing like you know what's funny
is
i started getting real serious
in the winter and then i went into like
it's funny i didn't know this about
myself now i'm completely sure
i'm about it because it's the third time
i'm doing it i didn't [ __ ] own a
computer
when i decided to launch winelibrary.com
did not
own a computer when i when i saw web20
and personal brand and content youtube
twitter
i had never given a speech
i got a d in speech in high school i
never
was a personality i never i think i
don't know if i was i don't think i've
ever been to los angeles
when i filmed the first episode of wine
library tv never thought of myself as
somebody that people would know
but i jumped in and went full throttle
gary beat it right
here i am and i realized what was
happening and i immediately went into
project mode and what it taught me was
[ __ ] i only learn from being a
practitioner
the only way i'm going to really know
this [ __ ] the way i need to know it to
invest
to consult to be about it is to launch
my own project
and so that's where i've been deep from
an ethereum
and my own project standpoint rainbow
wallet
non-caso custodial gas but
i can't wait for this summer to like
really go on that learning tour and i
think having an investment vehicle like
aj and i
phil toronto who might be in the room
right now who's been my guy guy
phil toronto the reason vayner rsc my
last fund went into coinbase
and roll like we've got the right team
we're a family and we're gonna go out
this hard and
you know i'm sure we'll be talking oh
i can't wait i can't wait that's for
sure and uh i'm sure
everybody else i i would never ever ever
i know you're
you're nervous about it and you don't
know what to expect but personally
i could never see this ever be a flop
just because of the amount of work
that's been put behind it
and the amount of how every single
person is talking about it i mean
and in a in a good light as well i mean
it's it's really
it's a big thing i mean you're if
there's one person i mean we've been
here
trying to sort of build a bridge between
the mainstream and the nft space right
and in every way we can
but you're gary vaynerchuk so it pulls a
lot of weight for sure
what what i like the most like i said
earlier you brought so many people on
discord taught so many people about
everything about crypto that now they've
probably seen their their since you've
been talking about i think these
probably doubled
so they're probably happy about that and
you've lowered the amount of ease that
it's gonna cost to buy into your
your nft so technically if they shift
some of the top
they're in profit as well so i think
this is pretty cool itself
and and there's a lot of there's a lot
of cool metrics to this as well it's
gonna be fun and i like that you're
making a five-day event
this is really interesting is there like
was there like a thought process behind
that or
why was it five days long because i
wanted to be able to see
what i think there's a lot of there's
two groups i'm worried about
and when i say worried i'm beyond
humbled and flattered
that these two groups are there one the
true og
whales who actually i think have
every day steadily over three months
gained
belief that i'm not full of [ __ ] which
and they know this project
is on the i mean the amount of coverage
in the mainstream media like
they know and so i know if i was a whale
exactly what i would be doing with this
project so i think they're smart
and then the non-crypto whales
that are in my life who've been
bombarding me who i've had like big
shout out to nick dio and tyler and
others who've been helping people
learn how to get a coin base and who are
like blindly in support of me people
have been asking to invest in me
for a long long time so i was like [ __ ]
they're gonna block out people so one of
the reasons it's a
five day event is i want to be able to
adjust to what happened i want to spread
it out
i want to like think this here are
things that i've done in the last week
as i've
felt the momentum built i've held back
more tokens
so i can give out free tokens to people
who couldn't afford it in my discord
i've lowered the price of my starting
price of a lot of tokens
you know i'm trying to do the best i can
in a world where you can't control a lot
once you mint and go on chain another
thing you pointed out is there's
absolutely zero
fiat involved in this that was important
to me i think
huge shout out to rohan again og big fan
of flow big fan of nba top shot
completely one of the watershed moments
of this era
and and and them and bitsky in love with
don
bitsky is awesome like there's a lot of
people doing epic fiat [ __ ]
um for me it was important to do a pure
play
on chain you know
like just i just wanted to do it in a
way that i knew would teach
i know who i am and what my contribution
can be
and i knew that i could destigmatize
and eliminate fear and help a lot of
people
learn the whole ethereum price increase
i mean
i mean i've gotten hundreds of dms today
in my discord like gary i'm sorry i'm
not going to buy
ethereum to the moon and i'm like great
like do your thing like
i'll be fine and trust me if you don't
think i'm gonna try to stick it to you
to outpace the currency i will um you
know like
but i'm really proud of that i'm
i really think i taught a lot of people
tik tok and linkedin like
i live for the admiration i get in my
dms and email
it's the best feeling do you understand
what it feels like
for hundreds of thousands of people to
communicate to
you that you did something nice for them
and ask for nothing in return
i feel like the karma you know what did
i call my karma character
andy what's karma is it a kudu
is it karma kudu by the way the best
part of the project
well i don't think it's kudu no it's i
think it's a bird
uh kiwi it's the karma kiwi because i
wanted to give a huge shout out to new
zealand
that i think does incredible stuff on
yeah it's a kiwi
like i think the karma kiwi shed its
wings on this one for me like the fact
that so many people
are gonna win on this project without
even buying anything because of what
happened with eth
makes my heart smile
i love that i love that and i love the
karma kitty
i think it's awesome well you said
there's some pretty insane [ __ ]
the gift code is crazy the gift goat is
a token that when you buy it
the contract says minimum six times a
year
over three years so 18 times over this
life cycle of at least the off chain
events
i'm gonna send gifts in the mail to
people
it's going to be a [ __ ] banana show
i'm i'm so excited about it
but that's the other thing like again
when it gets a big headline of the
of the revenue this project makes
nobody's thinking about the 300 000
in salary of the two people that i need
to hire just to buy
[ __ ] for gift goat
so this is a real undertaking i decided
to go [ __ ] for it
but yes gift code i think i think
somebody's going to take the gift goat
model and build out an entire game just
on
that concept alone
you know what it was i was so affected
by woot
how many og's in here hit me up on
twitter right now if you're listening if
you remember woot.com
which was absolutely the precursor to
groupon and livingsocial
and amazon bought it w-o-o-t and they
had like a
surprise box um
and it was like just the greatest you
would just
buy it i do what secret wine offers all
the time
like with wine text like there you go kj
he remembers uh let me just follow kj
here that's been the other part it's
been so fun to like i've completely
upped my community game on
let's go michael love this montgomery
has been great
twitter and clubhouse the perfect like
and crystal crystal remembers that
anyway
um that's kind of how gift goat is like
and remember
that's what's so fun for me gift goats
gonna start at 15e floor of five
i'm gonna look at how it plays out and
i'm in control then
of what comes and so it's gonna be a
[ __ ] blast
like i'm just so i don't think people
actually understand my energy behind
this project
i really don't
yeah it goes very very deep and i think
we can really hear it for everybody
who's
curious about that everything we're
talking about right now one more time if
you go to vfriends.com or
i just tweeted out the link to just meet
the v friends directly since we're
talking about gift code and
and every and all the all the characters
and the
breakfast bad french bear lunch ladybug
dinner deer
hangout hawk i mean the names are so
cute and i love them you know
and the way you put them on a car and
everything by the way you just reminded
me
i've been so lost in this whole space
that i have 60 cards still at psn
there's a bunch of charizards in there
so i'm pretty excited about that
totally forgot about that but uh but i
love to see these characters and i think
they're so
awesome what's what's really what's
really fun for me on the 268
characters is like i'm looking right now
at the
at the beta site right i'm looking at
legit llama right
and i'm just like when i look at it i'm
like man
like this is drawn in a way where like
on a hoodie or like like there's just so
much i'm thinking about right like
workout wolf it's a very unique one it's
a very expensive one because it comes
with a workout session with me and mike
vicanti my trainer
and don't forget all the access ones are
actually multi-year tokens
so people will get it and then they get
to decide what they do with it
but like when i look at it i'm like yeah
so that's workout wolf but
yes i'm building my kind of pixar right
but i'm also a cpg guy
so why can't i convert workout wolf
into a protein bar brand or why can't i
jv with
a protein company like like i that
i'm excited to really show who i am as a
businessman
because gary v is such a
overarching reality that over the last
seven years i don't think a lot of
people realize that i've built a 250
million dollar
a year revenue independent shop i built
with ben leventhal who really drove the
business but i was the co-founder and
and investor in something called rezzy
which
went head-to-head with reserve which was
all the uber gang
we won we built the best restaurant app
that was new
we sold that for hefty nine figures to
amex
i also while doing garyvee and building
vaynermedia
launched winetext.com which everybody
was listening to signed up for for my
dad
which completely revolutionized my dad's
business and rebooted it to the levels
that it was at when i was running it
also
i launched empathy wines during that
time
and which was an 18-month execution of a
direct-to-consumer brand
which we sold for a massive exit to
consolation brands
like i don't know like i think i'm
grossly underestimated as an operator
and like this is going to be fun to like
show the breadth of those capabilities
oh yes now you're making me more excited
about this because
when you say you can you know go and tie
it up to a freaking
protein bar company you actually can
chances are
i mean you have clients that have
protein bar companies
and friends and i mean vaynermedia
you know i'm looking at drock and andy
right now like nina like like if you
if you understood
what my last 24 hours
looked like in business development for
this intellectual property
you would [ __ ] your [ __ ] pants
i i can only imagine so and while you
talk about d-rock and andy first of all
what up i freaking
love you guys and second of all i mean
it's the the amount of work that your
team has put behind these must be like
i mean you guys must have been going
non-stop it's it's
it's it's insane i mean i'd love to know
what how did that you know
you know the team is andy's
andy's a king andy k like i should
probably give him all my tokens
like what he's done is revolutionary
like he's just been in it with me
in the biggest way ever um
yeah i mean everybody just the whole
everyone's been going at it you know
what's funny maha just reminded me
what's so funny about this is so many of
the things that um
you know that uh
um this is about have a lot of nuances
to what i did
a year ago in the all in challenge you
know michael rubin created all in
challenge and
and i really was kind of a wingman and
we raised over 60 million dollars
to feed the hungry during covid and
it was all access right it was like bid
on this and get this with this or be in
a movie with leo and
it's just so funny all your things how
they go right or or
you know going back to like my shout out
to andy i'm sure if andy went on the mic
right now
his shout out would be to steal who's
just been incredible on my team who
manages my personal crm but has been a
godsend to
to andy so like you know there's there's
always a trillion things going on that
get you somewhere
yeah it must have been an interesting
dynamic and i love that you talked about
the
challenge because that's exactly what it
was like at the end of the day you were
literally
it's again tokenizing access and time to
certain things for a donation for a good
cause and
i don't remember exactly how much you
guys raised but it was impressive to see
how much was raised
so fast for a good cause i mean wow
again back to the ending with the team i
think it's it must be so funny one day
wake up all right guys next 45 years of
my life
i'm doing this project i it doesn't
matter there's no board meeting that
that's what's happening
yeah it's it's you know it was 59.8
million
on all in challenge.com i think i think
yeah and i think my team's prepared for
that like i talked to them about
you don't understand we're building
infrastructure we're building
infrastructure we're building a culture
we have no idea where this is going to
take us like
i had no idea that we were going to
build original ip
in nft land it wasn't even a
conversation in october
i was talking about like many other
things but like but they were with me
when we were building out a toy two
years ago called workplace warriors
with these exact characters you know
this is why like it's so like this is
what's so funny about life right when
you see people
like having res this is one of the best
parts of the drock journey for me
is having the receipts [ __ ] you gary
tweet
[ __ ] you garyvee just dabbled some [ __ ]
together and throwing it out there and
[ __ ] like
i'm like cool here's a here's a video of
me two years ago
trying to do the same exact thing in toy
form
right oh [ __ ] gary like didn't know
what [ __ ] blockchain was a minute ago
cool here's a video for me from 2017
talking about ethereum at length like
that's the best part like you know and
that's why
for everybody who's listening like talk
about the things you know
it will always work out
oh that's the best way to remain as
authentic and
real as possible and the best way to not
burn out because the more you fake it
the
least you can actually go into the
consistency that's why you always preach
consistency and
one thing i noticed is it's just by
being true to yourself again you're true
to your art
that's how it's going to last forever
victoria i've i've been seeing you
avidly clap this entire time
and i want to hear your thoughts and i
want to know if you have a question for
gary because
we have a lot of conversations since
months about all of this space and
everything
you're pretty deep into i'd love to hear
oh thank you so much for
yeah like i'm just loving everything
that gary's saying right now
because it's all so relatable and i i
want to comment on
on a bunch of things the first one being
how some of your nft friends were
razzing you saying that your art is not
art first of all i i argue that
and here's why um it's not because of
the doodles
or anything for assault is obviously
your art because you drew it
okay that is art second it's just a
facet
of what your actual art form is and what
your art form is
is business entrepreneurship that's your
art
and these these drawings
they're just a pain stroke in your
canvas
in your masterpiece they're just a small
piece like the way you're talking about
everything right now you sound excited
exactly like
you know a little boy who just got a
pack of sports cards and he's like
opening them up
it's literally what you felt like and
i'm here for it
you know because like just like you i
would also go thrifting and go
to garage sales because i used to be a
huge video game collector
like dude like i i haven't toured 2600 a
5200
original pong unit a [ __ ] nintendo
famicom the original from japan
like i was no joke bruh bro let me show
you my collection people like [ __ ]
but like yeah but like it's so relatable
though
you know because it's that's just that's
what you love and that's your art and
your business the way
you think things through you plan it out
the way so many of us
artists do and like i've been in that
situation where people have been
neglecting
my art i'm a software engineer i love
programming
computers are my canvas you know like my
code is my art man
like someone the other day asked me do
you write poetry because we're having
like a poetry corner on clubhouse
and i'm like i don't write poetry i
write code that's my poetry
and that's just the way i exist
thank you i so i i so get it like
i i feel way more creative
than i feel like business finance right
like
i don't even talk to my cfo i have no
interest
i'm so not driven by the trophies okay
the money or the things you can buy with
it like to me entrepreneurship is such
creativity
and like and i you know
you know what's funny me being a
personality
or me being an author like all my
friends from like junior high are like
who are reading this stuff and back
channeling with me they're like they
remember me doodling a lot i used to
doodle
i was very ridiculous in school that's
why i was such a bad student i would
draw my faces on the chalkboard like i
was
i used to draw wrestling figures all the
time
they like my friends are like man
it's so funny to see everybody accept
you as a
five-time new york times best-selling
author
but not as an artist because we know you
and like
the book thing's far more ridiculous
than the art thing
yeah dude i think you're a wonderful
artist
those books wonderful art your entire
business infrastructure beautiful art
and it's something that i could
appreciate and look at it and be like
damn that's awesome
and it makes me feel something just like
art thank you
i love that that was beautifully worded
thank you so much uh
victoria uh wolf you're with us you've
hosted
a ton of nft rules uh especially the
most notable one was actually the time
magazine group
and keith is on stage with us like
grossman as well
and wolfe have you had the chance to
look at the fee friend
yeah yeah i was lucky enough to be on
that zoom call up uh quite a few days
ago i
thought it was so exciting such an
awesome concept i love the dutch auction
it's a decentralization of almost
monetary elitism in a sense
i love the personalized doodles as
victoria said it really
feels like a part of you gary i love
that you're only
accepting each as a forum as a way to
teach people
a form of financial literacy and
onboarding people on a crypto and
blockchain
and then most of all i think the beauty
in this is the tokenomics
and the relationship to experiential
events
garyvee events the one-on-ones uh coming
out of kovid i think we're heading into
a roaring 20s of live experiences
and this just feels fresh as [ __ ] and
i'm here for it
i appreciate that that means a lot
coming for you thank you
i love that speaking of speaking of the
devil just a little earlier i was
mentioning a tweet and i was mentioning
a collector that i absolutely admire
that i had the chance to recently be
connected with
oh shiny what's up what's good
i mean it's a pleasure to be here gary
congratulations
for persevering on on making sure that
everything's
perfect and up to your standards um you
i'm sure you could have dropped it
last week i'm sure it was close to being
ready um but but it's really nice to see
and if i could just give you a little
bit of my perspective
on what you're building
did we lose him
did i get kicked out i sure did
is going to increase the value of this v
friends over the long term
i i just dropped for a second i
apologize i'd love to hear though the
insight
well i was just saying gary that really
it's what's what's
incredibly special about the drop that
you're doing is not the drop itself
it's that you're allowing for community
to be fostered for the next 10
20 years and of course you're the
central node in that and you're going to
provide that value for the next two
three years i mean i know you have plans
provided for
20 30 years but the the real special
sauce in this
is that when everyone congregates
they're going to create their own value
and then your community is going to be
able to monetize in completely different
ways and create value for themselves in
different ways and then start creating
value for other communities
right that's that's the the long-term
business that's so exciting that you're
creating here
for me i appreciate it i'm really i am
excited i'm
i'm i feel like i remember with web 2.0
i felt like i was the guy
you know that could commun one thing
i've definitely realized about myself
i did it with wine because wine is
complicated intimidating i did it with
social
and i feel like i have a knack for it i
just have a lot more education to go in
nft
but the parts that i do understand and
have a good feel for
there's a translation engine in my head
that makes me communicate things that
reach a lot more people
like i got bombarded after cnbc and cnn
by all sorts of celebrities politicians
business people like they're like oh now
i understand nfts and so
i do feel a sense of responsibility of
that
gift and when i fall in love with an
arena
i want to lift the whole thing up like
to me the greatest way to be selfish
is to be selfless and like i feel like
i'm
i'm very excited to be involved and i do
think this project
is going to really help i really do i
think it's gonna help more and more
and more as i continue to do things i
think it's gonna
i like giving blueprints for people to
you know refine
make better by the way i love seeing
people come along and
and do the content model and the
community management that i've done to
be
much bigger versions of quote unquote
bigger versions of me or
or or small little versions where they
get what they want because i think
winning for me and success
one of the things i want to do with v
friends is redefine success
like not being anxious and actually
being happy
is a hell of a lot bigger win in life
than making a million dollars
and so like we need to desperately
bombard the conversation
damn i i love it this is we you know i
just
i just love hearing from you and and
live is even much better of an
experience much more fun and cool than
watching your videos i mean this is so
cool hearing from you and how much
passion there is i mean it's it's really
freaking
dope gary and i love that the best way
of being selfish
is being selfless i mean i hope some
people are still taking notes here this
is cool
uh i love that and this is absolutely
amazing definitely tweeted gary by the
way he's very active on there if there's
any way to
get to him right now and you know share
your thoughts your feeling is definitely
uh on his uh twitter uh you know another
another talk about doodles and
and people talk about simple doodles dr
seuss your hat looks pretty simple and
draw
is that art i'm just kidding rhett
what's up brother
yeah what's up man gary what's up it's
good good to hear your voice again after
the
zoom call thank you brother sam thanks
for being here
yeah i just uh for the people listening
i think the most interesting thing about
you is
uh this might have been last week i was
reading an article about
you talking about an nft winner coming
and uh
and leave it to you in the face of in
the face of winners coming
to to find time to drop your own nft
collection
and i think what everyone needs to
understand is that unlike many athletes
or some other people are trying to get
the quick buck which you
i've obviously talked about so far you
are in it for the long game you see
past the winter to the summer to the
spring to the summer and i think it's
it's shown by these by these cards and
and and the actual value they have for
many of these first-time nft buyers what
they can actually
to get in the real world but but also
hold on to um
in their nft collection uh and i just
kudos to you man
i appreciate that i was like that is
some that those are some big cojones
right there you gonna state that
and they'd be like you know what mainly
because
in that internet winter stock
that i knew was coming i was building
wine library and i knew all these
pets.com i knew it because wine.com
raised 154 million dollars
and i was a cockamanian 24 year old
sitting in new jersey beating the [ __ ]
out of them because the people that were
running it had no idea how to run the
business in the wine business
and that's how i was like oh these
people that get a lot of money like
oh okay and so you know
yes i think that's going to happen here
but you know i remind people
in that 1999 2000 and that really
collapsed in march
and april 2000 you know amazon
and ebay stock was sitting there
it was sitting there at a dollar you
know what i mean
and those are real companies for the
next 20 years and so
that's kind of how i see it yeah my
mom's still
still still slapping my dad about not
not listening to her
you know she was she's the one that all
those all those
all those great tech advice in the early
2000s my dad was too stubborn so
there you go
you should always listen should i always
listen to the happy wife happy life yeah
but i wanted to ask another question too
um
so there's gonna be obviously with this
five-day event
uh to say there's gonna be the same
amount is it
is the allocation the same amount each
each each day
i mentioned this earlier 48.72
tomorrow 19.996 the next day
11.8 then 9797
so kind of staggered out
boom i love it thank you for uh for
saying again that way people
can get a five-day drop i'm excited for
i mean it's gonna be an exciting five
days for you
you're probably gonna stress out the
whole five days but but that's great i
did mention
um a keith grossman just a minute ago
keith
uh i i like your profile picture by the
way how you doing
hey how are you i'm so just in full
disclosure i am like a boring old jewish
man in a much younger body
so i'm about to go to bed but more than
anything else i just
am a huge fan of what gary's doing and
like i just think that
you know everyone at times just rooting
for him because he's thinking about it
the exact right way
and so gary i thought your interview
with julia
chandling on cnn the other day was
amazing i thought your comments about
people thinking about this industry in
30 minutes or 30 years
was or 30 hours 30 years was spot on
and just rooting rooting the whole way
through for you
that's very nice thank you so so much
really
by the way gary um i know you're a new
yorker and an og
oh you're gonna
are you sure you want to ask him this
question you're going to be very
disappointed
i do appreciate the kind words coming
from you but that's where you and i
disagree strongly as much as i love you
respect you but
gary um new york bagels or montreal
bagels because i'm a money for all of us
[ __ ] this is i actually think montreal
bagels are better
now on the on the flip side let
let there be no let there be no
confusion that might be the only thing
that montreal is better than new york at
i'll take that i'll give you that i'll
give you that i'll take it
what about smoke meat jay oh smoke me
too oh there's another montrealer
hey team i'm i'm so i'm sorry to cut
this short but there's a lot of qa to be
done before tomorrow so i'm going to
bounce
i love everybody here thank you for the
time i hope thank you
i i everybody to just say you really
[ __ ] crushed it clubhouse has been
slow you've kept it a thousand people
concurrent
the entire time that's a big deal these
days in clubhouse and [ __ ]
all the way to the moon with garyvee man
[ __ ]
thank you guys thank you cheers